yo tout le monde s'est excusé jeunes
gens se retrouvent sur gouv ball gobbi
ce qui a été créé par les mêmes mecs qui
ont créé sumotori le jeu un peu bizarre
c'est parti c'est tout simplement un
match de foot
un temps il va la bête arrêt du goal
attend le mec arrive à mettre un truc
l'oméga
qu'est ce qui se passe je laisse
europcar et volt shoah il n'a pas
compris laisse mon joueur laisse le
laisse le il n'y a pas de ya pas de
corner ou coup franc dans le journée
bien d'accord c'est juste pas possible
mais laissez moi passer [ __ ] mais il
fait quoi lui il est décédé je trouvais
quand je souhaitais dans le il a rien
dans le dans les faits c'est bon art est
allé au nom c'est la femme du temps quoi
temujin [ __ ] de secte ce méga glauque
25 balles c'est parti pluie abat il part
dans les cages sans ballon t'as pas de
ballons t'as pas de ballons à labatut
vous rachetez aide
hop voilà gymnastique arrête de rire ça
suffit ce cas qui vient qui m'observent
en train de jouer actuellement mec mais
c'est c'est d'un rider il se fait que
non c'est pas comme sakho dont toi mais
non mais arrête de faire l'exercice mais
je sais pas où ça va nous mener 1 voit
la super haut il fait un petit show pour
publics jeunes arrêtent de faire la
tortue
hier facebook sous le ballon lui
carrément au web est qu on va faire un
mini terrain
aux dires et les [ __ ] d'animaux aller
marquer oui on va réussir à la mémoire
des morts voici c'est juste sur est ce
que c'est vraiment des cats ou cdd et à
jéricho
par contre on va mettre trop de ballons
à a été un terrain il a explosé
carrément ok ok ok mais un peu mais sa
joie bordel de merde et rouillard il
fait si bon on joue au foot bordel peu
supris un but et tout le monde tombe et
tout compte fait que les épilepsies
c'est bien ségo ball salle est trop pour
moi le retour du poulailler
oui nous allons marquer oui ok quoi est
ce que c'est une saison pas sur le
ballon comme i want is you be si vous
marquez pas je vais vous punit
attention vous êtes sûr très bien
punition c'est parti mon pc au pc va
carrément craché regardez bouger et
qu'on les transporte des [ __ ] de
compteur puis sont contents ils sont
contents d'en reporter et sa buse
c'est parti un contre un je suis
footballeur mois up but le terrain il y
montre comment voulez vous que je marque
et l'a étiré la butte
moi j'y crois hop très bien la balle a
bougé d'un centimètre et mélia je vous
jure qu'à un pedobear qui missionne là
depuis ma webcam avec ça et rigole dès
que je joue mal quoi ces médias
stressant au gharb est la taille
initiale des balles à la baule elles
sont carrément petit attendait mais
c'est ma seule chance de gagner tu as
fait cet homme il part au liban sans
plus
là normalement tout le monde court tout
le temps vers les balles on dirait le
débarquement tu mets une musique épique
self est tellement
regardez elle y va elle y va elle y va
elle y va elle n'y va pas à l ol va ali
m'a appris que cette incroyable mais
glisser dessus c'est quoi ce terrain il
donnerait tapas possible quoi le terrain
à la varicelle la très bien tirs dans la
balle allait non tu lui a tiré dans la
côte
ok il ya un mec qui s'est cassé la
colonne là bas allez le décès l'essai
dont tous ensemble on est bien c'est pas
des cages de foot ça c'est des caches de
saint-roch bordel de merde c'est des
vrais cash kohail a ça dans des seaux
qu'est ce qu'il fait lui mon dieu
clic as c'est que ça aux houches aime
bien ça avec skis au québec toutefois
numéros de cirque et je peux à we are
est le moyen des comme ça tu arrêtes à
il se passe un truc derrière mais on le
voit mais qu'est mais qui fait ça dans
la vie quoi alors j'arrête une planche
sur des noix de coco sur une planche un
peu plus grosses ne peut pas les prendre
et les mettre quelque part non n'est ce
pas possible parce que quelqu'un peut me
répondre
doit il y en a qui caresse à hambach
comme ça que j y crois qu'on le voit pas
mais on le voit arrête
non les mecs [ __ ] mais et mais ils ont
le qi d'un butin de poulet chante dans
le ballon mais chut vraie mort de deng
aller mais n'ose pas l'avouer bonne
technique pour atteindre le vélo la
roulade un bonne technique
non non non non on va saisir toi
ressaisis-toi john john voilà empêche le
fait la tortue solo ballon john fellas
dorthe sur le ballon alors non mais là
faut que je fasse demi tour c'est juste
un mot aussi chaude dans ce [ __ ] de
balle au nom non j'étais pas demandé de
te jeter sur la pancarte non on a dit
pas de reproches pattes
voilà moi je lève le pied quand j'ai mal
voilà tout aussi apparemment ouais bien
sûr tous les deux mots d'accord donc le
ballon lui a mis une claque qui lui a
dit dégage cote voilà comme ça tu
attends tu te tournes
non arrête de lever la jambe tu te
tournes j'ai dit et tu y vas non mais
pas le groupe écarts n'ont toujours pas
à sympa la figure qu'est ce que tu fais
avec
mais qu'est-ce qui fait l'état flashé
sur le mur bon voilà c'est fini la balle
avait bien trop loin du terrain à mais
merde on peut marquer en dehors du
terrain c'est vrai vu que les cachets
sont carrément énorme mais arrête de
tomber là j'en ai marre et retire cette
couche
oh oui c'est ça acclament mois et
l'allemagne était en deuil c'était quoi
ça c'est d'un coup tu as fait un avc ou
comment ça se passe et arrête de sourire
plus tard il te barge de succès des
coûts et malgré tout tu souris
attention attention non arrête le
pedobear de webcams là ok il a tenté un
truc
ok on a tenté un truc y'a rien à manger
sur le ballon tu arrêtes non mais les
macaques mais arrêtez de vous embrasser
[Musique]
est ce que quelqu'un fait ça quand il
tombe et qui se relève dans la vraie vie
[Musique]
c'est bon mais non mais je veux gagner
un match sur déconner c'est un mail ro
et quand même un peu bizarre comme
manière de célébrer la ruda tu as même
est ce qu'un jour ils s'arrêteront non
moi j'aime moi je suis joueur de foot
mais qu'avec les grosses bases pour ça
que j'ai perdu avant voilà arrière
regarder
regardez voilà après bon le facebook
s'te plaît voilà je bouffe et le carton
il tape car dans sa tête contre le sol
mais ça suffit d'être beaux jours comme
ça mais c'est scandaleux
moi je suis pas du tout mauvais joueur
en plus je veux dire une minute avant il
y en avoir mais dooya budget fait un
arrêt j'ai plongé touchés
s'ils font des avc dont je lis
régulièrement il ça leur arrive ya un
truc qui pète tu feras attention tu es
une grosse verrue au coude a dit la
gymnastique artistique mais non mais
make
bon je vous avoue qu' un truc qui me
tracasse depuis tout à l'heure est ce
que ces mecs on marchait dans un gâteau
au chocolat voilà est-ce que c'est
normal d'avoir des pieds comme ça bien
sûr que non j'espère cette vidéo sur ce
petit sumotori version foot vous aura
plu en tout cas se trouve bientôt d'une
nouvelle vidéo et on se quitte sur la
discothèque la plus impressionnante de
la planète
[Musique]